there's been a fire
in the baby's room
what
stop god i can't believe we haven't
talked about this meghan markle sharing
a shocking story from the trenches of
motherhood revealing her son archie's
nursery once caught on fire
let's talk about this for a second the
duchess of sussex relives the nightmare
on the premiere episode of her podcast
archetypes with megan it unfolded in
2019 while megan archie and prince harry
were on a royal tour in south africa the
moment we landed we'd drop him off it
with this housing unit that they had us
staying in he was going to get ready to
go down for his nap we immediately went
to an official engagement in this
township called nianga megan explains
how she and prince harry had to leave
their then four-month-old behind with
the nanny while they went on to an
official speaking engagement nearby
and we came back everyone's in tears
everyone's shaken we get back our
amazing nanny lauren in floods of tears
she was supposed to put archie down for
his nap and she just said you know what
let me just go and get a snack
downstairs let me just bring him with me
before i put him down in that amount of
time that she went downstairs
in the nursery caught on fire there was
no smoke detector someone happened to
just smell smoke down the hallway went
in fire extinguished he was supposed to
be sleeping in there thankfully archie
wasn't harmed because of the nanny's
quick instincts but megan says the
incident forced her to make a tough
decision
and what did we have to do
go out and do another official
engagement i said this doesn't make any
sense can you just tell people what
happened
and so much i think optically
the focus ends up being on how it looks
instead of how it feels we had to leave
our baby
yep the palace forced the duke and
duchess to put work first now megan is
doing things her own way and this
podcast is just part of her plan
it's been more than a year since meg and
harry inked their multi-year deal with
spotify this is their first real venture
and post-royal life and thus far it's
it's looking to be very successful back
in march megan teased the focus for the
pod we dissect explore and subvert the
labels that try to hold women back
i'll have conversations with women who
know all too well how these typecasts
shape our narratives
and megan definitely delivered her
promise by having her longtime friend
and tennis legend serena williams on as
her first guest serena also gets candid
on the show teasing her fears and
addressing unfair treatment as a female
tennis pro there are some experience i
didn't deserve at all oh my gosh course
you were treated completely unfairly it
hasn't it just wasn't one thing i'm
telling you the reason that i have
trauma from it is because it's been five
things or more
we think the conversation is exactly
what megan teased uplifting and
entertaining serena who recently retired
also discusses the double standards in
her professional sport i was afraid to
be serena because of all the experiences
that i've had and i i can't win being
someone different i have to win being
serena and
sometimes that's more fierce but
is it fierce when you know guys are
saying come on and and pump in their
fists it's pretty exciting but for me
it's pretty
it's aggressive
oh my goodness i'll never forget there's
one article that said this guy was
passionate and i had a meltdown
and next up megan is sitting down with
pop diva mariah carey
so we're looking forward to hearing more
candid convos and a behind the scenes
look at megan's life on the podcast so
far we're impressed pretty special
[Music]